a deadly officer involved shooting in
Hawaii after a suspect charged at police
with a 24-inch machete put it down
put it down put it down
put it down the Maui police department
released body camera footage of the
incident that happened on April 30th
family of the 40 year old Nathaniel Naki
called police saying he was acting quote
disorderly at a press conference this
week officials confirmed there was also
a temporary restraining order in place
prohibiting Naki from being on that
property body camera footage shows Naki
walking toward officers with the machete
in hand as soon as they arrive on the
scene
put it down
put it down put it down I don't remember
you put it down now put it down put it
down
refuses to put down the weapon he's
tased
throughout the altercation officers
repeatedly tell Naki to put down the
weapon but he refuses put it down
put it down
Nathaniel
Nathaniel put it down I'm telling you
I'm telling you put it down officers can
also be heard telling Naki they don't
want to shoot get down put it down put
it down
put it down
at one point Nagi gets into an argument
with officers saying they are wrong
wrong put it down you wrong you wrong
you know
come on put it down Channel
down put it down
put it down thank you Daniel
come on put it down
no what you did was wrong I told you so
much times no go over there you keep
going over there I keep telling you
don't go over there
you did go over there Maui officials say
they told Naki more than 70 times to
drop the machete and 29 times to move
back yeah you're not supposed to go over
there
just put it down listen to me
put it down
no no no no drop the machete drop the
machine drop the machete bar drop the
machete drop your guns right now no you
drop your machete
put it down
hey hey put it down
put it down put it down put it down like
right now put it down stop stop
put it down we put it down at one point
Naki listens to officers commands and
steps back put it down
oh God
yeah back up but seconds later he
disobeys the commands again
back up stop stop
it doesn't matter put him down put it
down come on put it down after that
officers quote almost simultaneously
opened fire at Naki when he stepped
toward them
officers on the scene performed
life-saving measures on gnaki until
paramedics arrived but he died as a
result of his injuries Hattie survived
he would now face multiple charges since
the shooting both officers involved have
been placed on administrative leave
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie